all right krista is with us krista's in
georgia hi krista welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up um
i have a question pertaining to student
loans
and i'm currently in baby step two
and my baby step two is primarily my
student loans
and of course as you already know with
kovitt going on
the government have reduced the interest
rates to zero percent
i'm at zero the interest rate is zero
percent and
i wanted to know in the sense of you
know being in the middle of baby step
two
is it because it's at a zero percent
interest is it better to try to knock
down the interest
of the ones that are quote unquote
frozen
or while at the same time paying off the
smallest
debt but then is it better just to focus
completely on the smallest student loans
all too bad look at it if you look at
all of the student loans added up equal
what
total is right at 80 000. okay
and if you add up all of the interest
being paid right now
under the current covit situation on the
80 000 it equals
x you may not know what that is but off
the top of your head right
but it's you're paying x in interest so
your total bill
between now and the time you pay it off
is x in interest
plus eighty thousand dollars right
correct
okay so if you pay ten thousand dollars
a month on eighty thousand plus x
it doesn't really matter which one you
pay off
mathematically you are going to end up
paying eighty thousand dollars plus x
follow me yes so you're going to pay it
it doesn't matter so let's do it with
the debt snowball which keeps you
encouraged
because you have measured traction that
way
and um so what's your smallest
debt your smallest student loan debt or
your smallest debt you said primarily
you have debts other than
student loans um just a
car loan in my
right now it's at 16 so it's right in
the middle of what
and what is your household income
it is 60 000 okay
and what do you do for a living i'm a
public health care worker
okay cool can you pick up extra hours
right now
unfortunately no i can see if they can
allow us to do like covet response yeah
but sometimes if you're able and if
you're able and willing
from a health perspective and so forth
to do all that stuff you need the income
because you got a lot of debt you got 96
000 in debt with a 60
000 income and so list your debts
smallest debt your small student loan
debt first and attack that with a
vengeance do not be doing any retirement
temporarily
no investing until you get this mess
cleaned up and if you do thirty thousand
dollars a year out of your sixty
thousand for three years you'll be done
that's 2500 bucks a month
yes you'll be done in three years
oh so that's beans and rice though isn't
it
rice and beans beans and rice that's it
baby you you got the plan you can do
this
i got you you can you can do it you call
back if you need help
but i would just get in the attack mode
list those things smallest larger start
plowing through them
throw up your hands touchdown every time
you pay one off run around the room
yelling a little bit and get back to the
next one
and a little celebration and keep going
and the more you pay off the faster
you'll move
the more fired up you'll get the deeper
you'll sacrifice the faster you'll get
out
um that's how this whole process works